el siguiente diagrama de cinta describe
la cantidad de pintura roja y pintura
azul en la pintura de color púrpura
ciruela así que este sería el total de
pintura púrpura ciruela y me dice que
está conformado por cuatro partes de
pintura roja y tres partes de pintura
azul la relación entre la cantidad de
pintura roja y la pintura azul es
proporcional en la pintura color púrpura
ciruela esa es la primera pregunta y
pues antes que nada no tengan el
diagrama puedo inferir que si tengo una
lata o una cantidad de pintura púrpura
ciruela entonces está conformada por
cuatro partes rojo y tres partes azul
dicho de otro modo la razón de pintura
roja pintura azul es de 4 a 3 o dicho de
un de otro modo la razón de pintura azul
ahora pintura roja es de 3 a 4 bien
entonces supongamos que tengo 4 latas de
pintura roja como en este caso entonces
cuántas latas de pintura azul necesite
para hacer pintura de color púrpura
ciruela pues yo sé que con cuatro latas
de rojo necesito tres latas de azul lo
tanto aquí la respuesta sería tres ahora
sí tengo seis latas de pintura azul
cuantas latas de pintura roja necesito
para hacer pintura de color púrpura
ciruela pues seis es el doble que tres y
si para hacer la pintura
recurrí tres latas de pintura azul y
cuatro latas de pintura roja para hacer
el doble voy a necesitar el doble rojo
así que necesitaría ocho latas de
pintura roja gráfica los puntos
correspondientes a la tabla ok vamos a
bajar un poco y nos dan esta gráfica así
que puede arrastrar esto y bueno yo sé
que el eje x es el eje de la pintura
roja y el lg y es el eje de la pintura
azul así que para cuatro latas de
pintura roja requiero tres latas de
pintura azul
para hacer siete latas de pintura
púrpura ciruela y para hacer
para hacer 14 latas de pintura púrpura
ciruela sí tengo 8 latas de pintura roja
necesito 6 latas de pintura azul
así que ahí está ahora si contestemos la
pregunta es la relación proporcional
pues vamos a ver en esta gráfica tengo
que esta es una gráfica lineal es una
línea recta que además pasa por el
origen y justo estoy diciendo que la
relación si es proporcional cuando me
dieron el diagrama de cinta dije que la
proporción siempre era de 4 latas de
roja por cada 3 latas de azul así que
esa relación si es proporcional otra
pista que es proporcional es que esta
gráfica pasa por el 0 pero bueno no
tenga que aquí si tengo 4 latas de rojas
requiero 3 de azul si tengo 8 latas de
rojas requiero 6 de azul y si tuviera
por ejemplo 12 latas de roja entonces
requeriría tres veces esta cantidad o
sea nueve latas de azul así que la
relación si es proporcional si la
relación es proporcional sequemos y muy
bien déjenme explicó con un poco más de
detalle ese último punto
bien pues yo dije que en la pintura
púrpura ciruela la proporción de la
pintura azul
la pintura roja con la pintura roja
siempre era la misma eso es lo que me
decía el diagrama de cinta y esa
proporción era tres partes de azul por
cada cuatro partes de rojo y de hecho de
aquí podría despejar multiplicando por
la cantidad de pintura roja y obtener
que la cantidad de latas o la cantidad
de pintura azul siempre va a ser tres
cuartas partes tres cuartas partes
y la cantidad de pintura roja empleada
por lo tanto si es una relación
proporcional la cantidad de pintura azul
es una constante por la cantidad de
pintura roja y noten que si no quisiera
hacer nada pinturas y uso cero latas de
pintura roja entonces usaría cero latas
de pintura azul por lo tanto todas las
relaciones proporcionales pasan por el
origen pasan por el cero y son una línea
recta son funciones lineales